[Music]
this is the story of the nation's wealth
about where money is who's got it
and how money shapes our society about
the spectrum between the extremes of
great wealth and grinding poverty it's
about what we mean by wealth and it all
starts with this man break me you can
never break you can roll your weighted
dice Malfi is eloquent thoughtful and
unemployed the knowledge that I seek is
worth more than you can pay you there
make your Menjivar get here and why your
hand a rapper waiting to be discovered
their hide behind the money looking down
to making fun of previous port and every
seeker mentioning her own
[Music]
he lives in a wick on the Essex coast
this is an area with a shadow that
includes the most deprived neighborhood
in England we're walking along here
gorgeous Beach yep you know and yet this
place is the number one officially
number one most deprived area in the
country that's why I love coming up the
beach because you when you're up here
you would not even imagine what's over
there you know it's not very nice down
there but people have to live there
because it's cheap in your music in your
rights and your lyrics yeah I get the
impression you're almost but I'm happy
about about the way money changes
people's lives if you come from a
background where you've already got that
you know it's an easier start in life
there's a lot of people haven't got
nothing that I mean Jay we're gonna hold
it unemployment is chronic in Jarek
there's been no big employer here since
Butlins moved out of nearby Clacton 35
years ago
for alfie perhaps for many of us the
question of where you find britain's
wealth can be confusing i need any money
to live and it's the Constructors you
know like thinking about as I say like
in the world is this plentiful those
people starving the things like that
even in this country there's people
starving you know that I can't I can't
get my drone there I don't I don't want
to be rich I don't you know that's not
why I'm laughter I just wanted to become
to country I'm happy down the road the
Brooklands estate the most deprived
place in the nation's most deprived
neighborhood a grid of narrow grubby
streets with unemployment illness and
crime in this story of British wealth
we've come to a place that probably has
less than anywhere else this is Lynn and
Ted who've lived tough lives on our
battle illness this place you've been
here for set six six years they moved to
Jay wit because the doctor told them the
sea air would help Lynn they've got no
savings and no income like many people
here they are dependent upon benefits in
a given week how much you spend on food
for yourselves well we were struggling
we were spending about ten pounds on
food ourselves for two people for a week
yeah
how much money at the end of a month
month would you have left over to for
savings or for going out nothing we
haven't been now the last time we
actually went out anyway worse by a
blast
what did you do we went over to
Colchester I don't go out clubbing I
don't go out drinking I don't take drugs
apart from what unprescribed yeah and we
don't go out to eat at restaurants for
argument's sake yeah we don't go to the
chip fish and chips shop and buy food
I'm in debt myself for about 5,000 pound
how stressful though is that a 5,000
pound that is it's nothing as your drop
in the ocean yeah he's a drop in the
ocean darling but it's the most to most
but to us to our sea it's been quiet
he's aborted yes it is to us yeah it has
been stressful and at times and I know I
shouldn't admit this but at times it's
made me cry yeah I'm not an emotional
woman but at times I've sat in and Ted
can verify yeah that's a tear and cry
because I can't I can't stretch it as
far as I need to stretch it but then
again you you we look at it this way
you've just got to make do where you can
yeah
[Music]
there's a strong community spirit here
but there are also some very vulnerable
people there's poverty and complex
social needs these are the most deprived
streets in England but you still get
lots of people who want to come here and
why well probably because property is so
cheap you can buy a house in this area
for below fifty thousand pounds and
that's less than just about anywhere
else in the UK it means even if you're
surviving on a pretty meager income you
still have a relatively affordable cost
of living and that balance between money
coming in and money going out is crucial
to the way we judge wealth across the
United Kingdom
J WIC is not that far from the UK's
richest region in London and the
southeast we can gauge inequality using
a formula called the Gini coefficient
the higher the bar the worse the
inequality the most equal region is the
southwest of England followed by the
east of England and the West Midlands
worst of all is London so next stop the
nations capsule the capsule has a
greater proportion of rich and poor
people than anywhere else in the UK
households here own property worth more
than a trillion pounds and the riches of
London have flowed into the Home
Counties on average households in
southeast England a region that excludes
the capital are even richer than those
in London here on the Thames we found
Simon and Sam regular musicians at a bar
where you can sing karaoke along with a
ukulele band
[Music]
you're great fun until someone mentions
the cost of living quite recently I was
borrowing money out of my sister student
loan so money could be better the price
of living is very high even though the
way did you get paid will be higher the
price of living is so much higher than
anywhere else it's not equal in that
sense and what about London's sky-high
property costs you know not even like a
middle suburban house back to a lot of
people when they hear I own a property
you're wealthy because your own property
that's something that's changed that
thing I fantasize about just having a
garden which is like ridiculous but
because I can only have a flat in our
house a garden has become the symbol of
luxury so here's a picture of British
wealth pensioners in the southeast and
London regions make up our wealthiest
households the worst off sector
single-parent households in Wales and
yes also in London if we factor in
deprivation yellow areas are well off
the purple ones have more social
problems and you can see the South is
generally richer than the north there
are enormous exceptions the poverty in J
wake and also well this
[Music]
welcome to Carleton Road in orderly edge
the most expensive lavish road in the
north of England in this corner of
Cheshire just 50 miles from Manchester
Holmes self and millions it demonstrates
another British trend well-heeled people
wanting to live near one another so you
sell tickets for this I'm assuming yeah
there's a lot that goes into this event
lots of champagne bringing glamour back
to Cheshire is what I would like to do
Johanna organizes glamorous events for
the rich and famous it's a very affluent
area to live I think it's a beautiful
place to live
and I feel there's a lot of
entrepreneurs there's a lot of business
people especially women but we're no
different to anyone else just normal
people
there must be something different though
there's no more people don't end up with
but what would it take them for you to
consider yourself financially wealthy
it's when I've got my Aston Martin so
that's it yeah that's when you get
across the line I think so mostly
networking groups in the area
little surprise then that Johanna is
planning an event in collaboration with
her favorite brand in this slice of
Cheshire Aston Martin is not so much a
car as an aspiration a sign that you've
made it we were the number one selling
dealer in the world for 2015 and 2016
and top five for last year in the world
in the world okay so we can be clear
here a lot of well-heeled of people
walking through those doors certainly
though
so we know there are extremes of wealth
and of poverty but most of us lift
somewhere in the middle and that's
probably also what we aim for there are
loads of ways of analyzing wealth you
can look at disposable income house
prices pensions you can look at
deprivation and consider all the
regional variations and when you put all
of that data together you find a few
places that seem to be sweet spots where
all the good bits are found in one place
so I've come to one of them hodsoll and
Staffordshire to see if life is as good
in reality as it seems to be and a
spreadsheet
this is Steve the butcher the shops been
here for decades we do have well a large
range of different types of customers
you know we have the customers that come
in and what's a nice treats that have a
nice piece of Philly steak and then
we've got the customers that they would
come and just for a couple of pounds of
sausage some mints when I said to you
but we thought this was a sweet spot
what was your reaction I was quite nice
because it's not something that you
necessarily think about but on
reflection it is a lovely place to live
lovely place to work the West Midlands
is not our richest region but it is in
places like cuts or where your money
goes furthest which makes it attractive
for young families living here means
that we can afford a nice house and the
other standard school private school
whereas if we lived in Harrogate it
would be a choice of one or the other so
definitely
it's an affordable place family-friendly
place wondering other things actually
about this place is it has quite low
inequality um I probably agree with you
know I've not seen much poverty
I think everyone sort of middle-class no
identity is leaving until perhaps to
retire
there are no clear answers about being
wealthy
perhaps because we're still wrestling
with inequality perhaps because that
word wealthy means different things to
different people do you consider
yourselves wealth yes yeah in what way
with what we've got together I'm living
my dream right now so I'm wealthy enough
but not yet financially but we're
building on that we have a lot of plans
no I'd say yeah yeah not got a lot of
money though because I've got a
beautiful family got a lovely lady
behind me you know I live in a nice
place people think it's full of defiers
I think it's beautiful
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]